this is a production of Cornell
University
I'm xx was in that instruction so I hope
our wines doing
find during the epidemic so today I will
talk about the watermelon genomics work
that my lab had been down for the past
ten teke a past decade
so what Melo Billups today settlers
genus and they could be the family so
this family also includes several
important vegetable crops like melon
cucumber and pumpkins so one melon is a
worldwide fruit crop and you can say
from this word through the map but
watermelon is grown grown pretty much
everywhere in the world even for
countries that are close to Ikea you can
see watermelon sign everywhere on this
world food map and the watermelon is
also a popular popular fruit car the
annual production of watermelon is only
behind tomato and a banana and around 1
100 million tons each year watermelon is
a nutritious crop and it contains high
levels of lycopene and it's higher than
any other fresh fruit or vegetables and
the bottom and also contains acetylene
this is amino acid that maintains
cardiovascular function and it recently
watermelon had to become an emerging
model crop for non climacteric food
development like Studies on sugar
accumulation rapidly further expansion
in the fruit of opinion and the same as
other Cuba the crops and water belong
can be used as a model system to study
the florists executes inhalation so
however the culture of watermelon had a
very very narrow
genetic diversity and it's sensitive to
Wario's packaging and a pathway
infections the trays that are interested
in breeding program are
no normally very complicated therefore
no modern genomic tools are needed for
watermelon to facilitate its breeding in
research so in 2008 we formed an
international watermelon Tanami
initiative and we have three objectives
the first one is to generate a
high-quality reference genome of
watermelon cut around nine seven one
three so this is a ratio tab Kodama with
early maturity and a high crude ecology
it is a deployed highly inbred and it
with the genome size of around 425
million base pairs and the second
objective is to resupply the twenty
representative watermelon genotypes to
generate a comprehensive genomic
statement operation map and they said oh
I to the perform large-scale sequencing
of watermelon transcriptomes
to gain deeper understanding of
important the biological process so this
work was publicly into early 2013
here are some must take home messages
from this project photo is a graphic you
normal watermelon was assembled from
iluminage Chaudhary's the genome encodes
23,000 genes and is this photo reference
for watermelon the watermelon had on
occasion a whole genome duplication
event shared by the Collier you record
showing by this peak of the three to
four tq8 distance and we've the we found
that there's no recent hojin
genomic education event occurring in
both me alone this is different from our
table sees you can clearly see two
recent peaks in Arabidopsis indicating
to reason how genome duplication so we
through analysis of watermelon genome we
can illustrate is your voting history
we explain how the 21 chromosome you
could immediate ancestors so this
Assessor had 21 chromosomes and how its
turn hua chromosome was transitioning
into the modern 11 chromosome a
structure of watermelon through a large
number of genome fittings and a few key
events we also found that a large
portion of disease visit energy and have
been lost during watermelon
domestication
so this domestication process mainly
focused on desirable for the ecology in
the year with the technology of the ones
we recently read assembled in a seven
bars regional using packet byelarus
by nano optical and has a chromatin
interactive maps so this new assembly
because watching to assembly the quality
is much much improved is much much
higher than the previous one and you can
see the and fifty scientist is more than
100 photo improvement of working one we
also compare the new assembly to the
442nd to the packs and the new assembly
coward almost 100% of all these four
packs accept the four three two bases of
this pack and later we check we found
out that this 42-foot study two pages of
the back second is from cloning vector
that means this sequence this assembly
covered more 100% of all four packs and
they the base accessory is were also
very high and you can see the identity
between the assembly and the bags more
than 99.9 percent from for three of them
and this Y is not an important as I'm a
person is still be much higher than than
the what you want you know so the the
body to assembly also consists hand with
high C maps the
in Attica maps and also the parent nano
object optical maps so this is a very
very high quality genome of NASA mastery
and after we parted the what you want
you know my assembly occurred email from
the Director of National Human Genome
Research Institute and indicated that
our work would select as a genome
advance of the mass and after we had the
waiting to genome of watermelon of the
NASA of a three hour we were invited by
a trend in genetics to write a short
essay to holler our work as a genome of
the mass so what this set Rosen allowed
the Guatemalan genome was highlighted at
the genome of the mask on tuned that's
next month so this in case that's must
be good at working on watermelons so
besides this calculus pieces a card with
a watermelon anitha's so there are six
other extant separate species and the
three of them the mucus of the promised
Amara's and the consensus had already
been used in the breeding program in
addition the the modern watermelon the
many have two groups wise Asia group
whereas American America group these two
group they show different fruit
phenotypes so after we finish the
sequencing the version one of NASA
members regional that's the East Asia
Kokua we plan to sequence an American
Dakota what memo these are collaborative
work with dr. Amano Larry we select the
chalice from Greek hardwa and this
discovery is considered the principal
American deserve watermelon and this
courier was released in 1954 and it was
the most popular commercially grown
watermelon in the United States for more
than a decade and had to be using in
numerous watermelon breeding programs
and in the development of many
or the cars so this caddy way is good
for largest land shipping and the
resistance to a
fidelium wheeled and as rocky knows and
he can see the fruit phenotype of
territory and the NASA
barre3 are highly different the
full-size are different the first shape
is different color flat color skin color
and iguana signals that are different
and the take-home messages from this
sequencing project is that the first one
is that a high quality genome was
assembled from chance and gray using
alumina Chaudhary's with the m50 scuff
of the lens of 7.47 meeting principles a
total of more than 210,000 snips were
identified between these two genomes
that is around one snip for 1.5 kilobase
I mean the is relatively low density you
can give you a comparison so the cartoon
of what tomato has tomato and temple
follow means direct ancestor had about 6
million snips of the 900 million base
pairs is much much more as near to put
in their two species we also identified
our total of 37 166 high confidence
largest variety of variations begins at
13 on average 400 were located within
fluid shape and a flood of elekid years
and as you can see from previous slides
the first shape and for radar are highly
different and this include
159 PP deletion in the CR FS wanting of
category there is no end to be
associated with elonka the fourth year
in chosen for
so as I mentioned earlier these three
species most of the promos Amara's and
the color census had already been used
in the breeding program so during the
past several years we have been
servicing an assembled a reference
genome for this species and we second to
the we really finish the December the
mucosal diplomacy genome you didn't
PacBio along with and it is the
colleague of this genome is extremely
high and you can see the contigo and
fifty size it's 27 million base pairs
and that's almost 1000 times of this
other assemblies that's what assemble
using you know many other ways but this
assembly also of high quality and for
mucosal diplomas most of the chromosomes
were assembled in bar 2 computers so now
we have one for most of the promise tool
for tomorrow's and wonderful Christmases
so this are not proper to the year and
the through comparison of this reference
genomes we identified a number of large
structural variations so here I give me
a why example is that a in the
chromosome where argument events that
are involved chromosome four and one
that this event will occur after the
novice and amaras
the word yet from consensus so the
Amaro's and not how do they have the
same chromosome structure of Vienna for
Part II have a large chromosomal in
Germany in this from Crassus
so recently we found a group of a Carter
what watermelon from West West West in
Sudan is Farage ethically really close
to the virus species and because of the
promise this group the barrels that
flashed not be the fruit and I could
represent the descendants of progenitor
population of the metrical watermelon so
in collaboration with Suzanne Remo we
assembled a white colored sample from
the for using PacBio laundries and we
assembled 307 60 7.9 million base pairs
along with a canoe on 50 site of 9.3 4
million base pairs
this is also a very high quality keen on
and we just finalized the genome
assembly the undertaking is still
ongoing so here is a summary of our
watermelon genome reference genome
sequencing effort so revenue genome have
been developed for 4 of the seven
accident accident accident several
species and the different groups of a
culture the watermelon we believe was
this graph in the genome will provide
valuable resources for watermelon
research and the breeding and a
comprehensible comparable analysis of
watermelon graph and genome sequence
will provide a critical insight into
watermelon orange in domestication and
the important a great agriculture traits
so watermelon is sort or anything in
southern Africa and as entity to Asia
Europe and America and then to the
entire world
so during domestication in the breeding
mode below the wild watermelon with
small fruits and the fruit is hard hair
colored and the bitter and this fruit
will improve in the modern tomato
a modern swig of water mellow carrying
large fruit and a crisp food sweet and a
red flash and a seeds and the paintings
of what melons have been discovering in
Egyptian pharaohs Tom's build more than
4,000 years ago
so that indicates that a watermelon had
been Tom's people for at least 4000
years
however there are several on us or the
critical questions related to watermelon
orange in evolution in education the
first one is what is the direct
progenitor of a cut above water mellow
second one we only Africa was the
watermelon first domesticated the solo
one the the autonomy of several species
is still in debate the fourth one is
what are the genetic basis of watermelon
domestication so to address these
questions we first character as this
follows Jon plant collection in
maintained in national planet young
plant system so this collection contains
114 hundred accessions collect and
acquire disregarded ward so this is a
part of the our killcam project so if
you're interested in in this using the
cooker project you can go to this
website to get more information so
exceptional in this collection that is
play great for the typical kawasaki and
we performed you not having by
sequencing 1365 accessions that include
1211 notice that Kerry was and 52
mucosal diplomas and 102 Amaro's
we generate about 25,000 the paralytic
snips with minor allele frequency
greater than 0.1 as there were and the
missing that already less than 50%
so using this GPS data you the slip from
the GPS data we can track the fellow
Jenica tree so why wine interesting
funny is that the exceptions the Silla
Natas accessions from sudan was Phillip
Phillip Phillip Phillip II Natalie very
close to the wild species MOOCs as
promised
so this suggested that the watermelon
could be for thematically in North
northwestern Africa
that's whatever we also down located so
that's also indicates that a modern user
watermelons could orange Italian north
north west in Africa using this nibs and
a historic data story in national
planning on plan system we performed a
genome-wide Association studies for
several interested in nutrient race
include fruit flesh color ground strap
pattern fruit shape and resistance to
bacterial fruit blush and the party
media risk to three to W and papaya
ringspot virus we identified some 101
bar and knowing loci that are associated
with this this trace and was indicated
by the green color we also identified a
number of no no what genome glosses are
associated with this trace and using
this lip data we developed a watermelon
collection so this collecting will
provide a public resource for future of
phenotypic and the Jeana Keough's
analysis of any trait of interest by any
labs and during the when we design this
when we confer this collection we design
strategies that include the following
Messer's or create criteria further away
this cocolate need should have a rhythm
reasonable size is not too big or not
not too small
so wasting its 400 oxygens around 400
using reasonable size and you to capture
if you the capital luckily the earlier
allelic diversity over the entire
population and also includes exertions
with some unique and important
economical trades so mainly we are
mainly focused on fruit quality trade
and individual resistance for watermelon
we select 379 accessions all this 379
sessions will be the net you know will
be Risa quest to attend to 50 next
coverage and a miracle of 100 oxygen
available a second - 100x coverage this
is mainly for pendulum construction God
will talk about later and all this data
were made public and will be apropos we
will produce seed for this collection
and generate a City stock and the city
will be distributed to the public
through the Jian plant genome Center and
a way below this would be extremely
useful resource for watermelon research
in the breeding this could be a major
achievement from our cacao project so in
the meantime we also perform the genome
research Racine for that was certain
logic settings so the this is a crappy
walk with dr. Jung she and a Bengali Oh
from China we did genome recipient of
414 accessions from all seven excellent
etc species and include 258 from Linares
cardio oz and 87 nunneries 19 mucosal
promos so the one Amara's and the 15
colistin series so the reason we only
have one or two
is erosive Remy I not in a nose it's
because this are unavailable accessing
the unit came back so we can get a more
exciting form this species we generate a
total about about 2.6 terrible data with
averaging the depths of each area depth
of 14 point of our X camera for 14.5 X
and average coverage of a nanny 2.2
percent of the genome we generate about
20 million snooze and a 6.7 million
small Indians and using this nips and we
construct a phylogenetic tree and from
this tree we Lucy we can illustrate the
fellow genetic and evolutionary
relationship of the seven extant species
instruments this as simplified in this
simple tree and we also perform a bababa
test to identify gene flows so we were
able to identify the inflow became
cirrhosis and amaras and cirrhosis and
Medusa diplomas and omocha sophomores
and an anarthas but we could not
identify anything flow between Amara's
and Democritus promise so this suggests
that Amara's and the lineage including
the boxes vamos and Linares man have
been derived from different ancestral
populations or the evolve independently
after the etymologies the fraternity
tree Frattini analysis the further
confirmed that primitive
watermelons from north and northeast
africa maybe the closest to the
progenitor of this widow book memo we
found out that a cardamom watermelon had
very low nucleotide diversity this car
was
and non erase this is a power value and
also the moccasins Apollo's has also
very low genetic diversity and
nucleotide diversity you can see the
powder is very low but the Newton
diversity in Kali census and armor is
pretty high especially in Christine says
that almost seven ten times higher than
that of the cars the FST value
consistent with the Philippine occur
relationship the democracies diplomas
are fricative closed to the to the cart
with the watermelon and you can say the
first key difference it's much closer
and as the Rd decay was very slow in
cars
Lana race and also most of the promise
but the the our dear DK directly in
Amara's and focus and Collison says this
is consistent with their genetic
diversity
I mean low genetic diversity the GDK
slower and the higher the negative 3 Rd
decay much faster so our collaborator in
China see the performer phenotype
findout phenotyping of this for 414
exceptions for this several interesting
traits
so using this high-resolution SNP data
we performed a genome-wide Association
studies and we were able to identify
several interest in loss I and the
underlying candidate genes where I will
not go through each one and the
expression profile of these candidates
during fruit development of NASA Masri
that is a cardio and a PIR tune are six
three four one that is the virus species
is our Mars
so the expression pattern for the
support
your role in this industries with that
identified the slack in swaps at a
different evolutionary stages of what
Melo
we compare we compare the Linares and
mucosal promos to identify the
efficacious waves we identified cars and
the land races to identify improvements
waves and we compare them because of the
promise and the consensus
Amara's and a collision say to an
advanced speciation tulips in total we
identified about 11 to 25 million base
pairs not about 3 to 7 percent of the
genome that are on those lacking at the
different stages of watermelon evolution
and this includes about 7 307 62 770
genes in this selective swaps
so why interesting funny is that we
found very few common genes that in two
multiplications web and improving as
well you can say very very few it's only
is less aa
is less than 2% so this indicates that a
different race or different a lot of the
same trails have been selected in this
tool to different process
so next I will talk about the the
full-size evolution so the fruit size in
college anxiously the very small is only
their part to one killer kilogram and a
1.7 in workers of the promos he's about
three point three three point five
kilogram in Amara's with the body
species and the nunneries and McCarty
was and currently we have five northern
cutie ours fruit with knowing freely
could he knows we found that if this kid
to kid ears under selection during post
domestication and the speciation event
you can see because your unit is
officiating when the different size
would already increased that may be
partly due to the selection of this de
Tolosa and also we found this qtr was
unlucky enduring improvement although
during improvement of this fruit size
was not increased but still so there are
still some loss there was an election
and these two laws are was not honest
like gene in any stages this may
indicate his potential for future what
melon fruit make fruit size
enlightenment so next we talk about the
the fruit taste the fourth way is
through the bitterness
so all consensus accessions and Amar's
oxygens they are bitter and or Carla's
love including Landorus and acharyas the
unknown Peter but in most of the
polymers
some of them are pedo some of the non
vedo
and we found that the CR BT gene does
the nineteen control the the fruit
bitterness
had been under selection you can you can
see had been unlucky into in the the
domestication it's a comparison between
bestowed upon most of his memories as
indicated by reduced the highly reduced
the nearly that new club diversity in
Daenerys and also high FST value between
the two groups we found a single base
mutation from c-to-t in this CR b TT
that leads to a premature stop codon of
Sarah Beattie and I will also further
accessions the numpy they are the
carrion bitter fruit we have the same
allele and all now beautiful they Karen
the Treo that means this alia was almost
fixed in the is largely fixed in the in
the carbon water Meno and it play
freedom a major role in fruit goodness
so next the fruit sweetness this could
be the most important trade in what
manner and you can see from the wired to
the calculate watermelon the first
witness was had been increased and the
the increase is mainly due to the
increase of fructose and sucrose and
raffinose and the statures
was decreased during this from wire to
the mathematic from by the cardio
process
and we found a CL 88 routine that are
occurring after collectors see their
gene that are known to be good to be
potentially involved in raffinose
metabolism and we found that team was
already sacrum for from early on in the
progenitor of sweet clip of sweet
watermelon and you can see in the
consensus that the Ginetta was really in
the class NC is very high for the
genetic diversity of Rhonda's gene it's
very very low in both locus of the
promos and cultivated watermelon and at
the expression pattern of this gene in
fruit development of Y of Cardwell
watermelon and a wild watermelon photo
suggest is raw in in sahaja termination
in watermelon fruit so our collaborator
young food group generate a crisper
mutant align to further confirm the
function of this team and in the
knockout line and you can see clearly
this the picture shows the color is
different the maturation is different
and all the mainly the the sugar content
is different the glucose fructose in a
so-called
or decrease in the mutant line while the
raffinose was highly increased and the
total suitable solid Condon was
equalized in this eternal life so based
on this data I may suggest that Sierra
82 cannabis to sugar on combination in
watermelon fruit flash through
facilitating the imitable
of revenues in the glucose fructose and
sucrose so we next checked the sweetness
QTL and we found that we have for
knowing few tears the founder one of
them was select impose domestication
an improvement
two of them were honest lacked in
communication and above them will only
select in improvement so this suggests
that commuting and original you know the
selection of genomic regions that
underline the same traits so next flat
color so you know achievers analysis we
identified the we found that the most
highly or social snip and this fruit
color for point of our locus was located
in this air ycb t LC Bobby jeans
so this snip which leads to a amino acid
change from phenylalanine to Hualien so
or TuneIn and red or pink flesh Linares
accessions carries the volume in a
wasabi so whereas the 14 or orange and
the 20 yellow flash the not has
accession and all wild oxygen which
which are white white flash which bears
bad flash fruit how does a phenomenally
so that indicates the importance of that
snip in determining the fruit flat color
and also the the during the from the
imported oil during the commodification
of wat mellow so we also found the
return was similar or flat color this
one would overlap with the sweetness
Korea so this QTL this clear harbors the
can ability in CST to an OE expression
of the seen cost both elevates tubular
and also needs to flash the current
development and a previous study
indicates that elevated sugar levels
activates the watermelon through the
chrome or brass localized v phosphate at
hot bottom and say our PHP 4.2 and this
leading to
quite not accumulation so this results
suppose that
consistently with that flat Carlo and
sweetness fruits with it these two
traits are highly correlated and they
can be crossed lactic during
domestication the next way we identified
the wide integral equation in the
watermelon can't even carry watts as I
mentioned earlier several wide species
like Collison says and amaras have been
usually in modern breeding program and
we identified two major integrations the
first one is the integration from
Amara's and this integration contains a
lot of genes related to party medial
resistance or tolerance to hypoxia and
the low phosphate conditions so we
identified another iteration from kala
census so this integration contains the
gene that contains a of Fusarium with
one resist in laconia with fo 1.4 so
this was summarized the major findings
from the original research engine
project it's a history from speciation
than to education and I improvement
what kind of trace was slack yet
automatic aided and what kind of genes
which genes and in which materials are
involved in this selection and also the
integration from one species what kind
of traits were you - where is what kind
of lost energy is were involved in this
integration so next I will talk about
the depending on so watermelon kids play
a wild phenotypic variations umpires
there are some Noah teams and a separate
they exist in certain exceptions so once
you know alone from my accession
couldn't provide a comparison with
reference to access the genetic
diversity on what memo so therefore a
Pantanal that captured the entire
the elements is needed so as I mentioned
earlier currently we have several
reference genome from different for
different settlers species and we also
performed ginamarie sequencing I just
mentioned 414 ginamarie sequencing
genomics kind of 414 extensions and
everything italy in collaboration with
Amano Larry Pat shaker we we sequenced
kala census so to deny licenses that's
sorry acts coverage we just finished
with the sequencing and with with we
serviced 115 our Morris oxygens with a
beautiful TX coverage and I will talk
about this this was used in our
preliminary pan genome analysis we are
in the process of generating
resequencing for another so di sorry
locus of the pomace accessions that's a
selects coverage and in the field near
future will be a performance sequencing
on the collection so this reference
genome and the genome 7 the data will
provide a solid foundation for one
watermelon pendulum construction so here
I will give you some preliminary results
of the pendulum can't reconstruct it so
we first constructed a species specific
up and announced so why is they asked
Amara span genome and because none other
and the mucosal palmarosa dear fellow
generally are very close so we combined
these two species to build one pan
genome and we found out in the pan
genome of these combined species did
combine and pan genome we fir we
identified only 2.5 million bass-player
non referenced you know but this
non-revenue contains more than 2000
novel genes but for um
we identified a much more not reference
genome that's 11
closer to a million base pairs but only
181 novel genes in this 11 million base
pairs so this suggests that this
non-resident genome mainly contains the
non-coding sequences we use exceptions
which whiskering 85% of the genome to
perform a presence and absence of
erasing analysis and a basis on this
variety analysis to me to our surprise
we found that the core genome component
of both Amara's and Alana's pan genome
are very very high
it's nonny wise nine eighty percent of
my to 96 percent you can see compared to
other pan genome only rice is a little
close to this watermelon but with males
in the tomato there are much much lower
so next we integrated it - panting them
into a saucepan genome is kind of a pan
of the pan genome so we analysis this
integrated pan genome and we identified
a photo 231 genes that I enraged in see
the lavas extensions and the Turin 93
that are you greatly
Amaro's extensions so I would give you
three example the first one is none and
yes there are genes these genes are only
present the present in almost all
Amara's accessions
but only finding mirror for you that not
has exceptions and this was confirmed by
the genome sequence alignment you can
see that Fuji's
there in the Amara's genome but not in
the not original and the decision was
later captured by the Pentagon because
the they are present in but those were
two exceptions and we found for us one
gene serving comparability genes work
has already also or amarra successions
but only present
- or for the knot has accessions this
make our ability to address our they are
see in another's and because we can find
a profit flower in in Amara's we also
far to 13 teams that are present in all
another succession but missing in
Amara's this could be related to our
rich fruit flange in another's so here
is the summary of the top so much more
rough in the genome have been generated
for different as well as species genetic
diversity and a phylogenetic
relationship of more than 1400
watermelon accessions
in the United States national planet
germ plasm system were compromised more
than 400 the representative oxygen is
belonging to the same extent several
species were resequenced and a
watermelon variety map was constructed
g1 Anna publishing genomic analysis used
in this world very own map provide
insights into watermelon imaging anatomy
teaching history and it will be a gene
on region underlying important traits so
cetanas pan genome is being constructed
so I want to mention that all the genome
data including the reference genome and
a genome variation data that we already
published
had can be accessed through the to give
you the genome database we have
developed so however enjoy the data
Monument
I hope you enjoy mine in the data so
finally I would like to thank the people
from my lab the current members sorry
the depended on work now so the dose
improve data current members and the
primitive members at the black the the
great job and the mill huge convergence
to this project I think in bizarre day I
can't do anything on these projects and
I also thank our collaborators we are
regenerated
data for our to eternal eyes and our
project was funded by USDA many through
the Kookaburra Jack and also by a
National Science Foundation the thanks
for your listening thanks a lot okay any
questions for Fay
can you raise your hand are your white
Chuck has a question okay
though I wonder if the sequence does the
sequence of what a watermelon provides
you with very information about these
chromosome fusion events that you said
create formation of the watermelon as a
species and I wonder what would that
would do to the genome structure and
collinearity so what's that was this
imply so basically you know if you have
two chromosomes that that that fuse
whether that affects the integrity of
the chromosome do you see like loss of
colinearity if you go outside of
watermelon and compared to two elated
species no actually they said the the
the color senses the retains the
ancestor was a mono the chromatin
structure only the modern watermelon
energy Amaro's that's a more closely
more recent what you know I can say
three words is it a Morrison those one
has the genome reality events of course
this brand your argument the events we
are preparing some characterization or
chromosome hybridization recombination
thank you other questions or you can
post them on chat if you'd like
see if I see any other questions nothing
on chat okay all right thank you thank
you Kay thank you everybody ever to
remind you guys to post your votes by a
week from Wednesday send everybody an
email thanks a lot
see everybody thank you bye so they save
you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu